this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base
a subscription website where you can
download thousands of medical
images and videos to use in lectures
courses
presentations professional training and
more for more information
click on the link in the description
laminectomy is the surgical removal of
part of the vertebral bone
called the lamina 24 vertebrae make up
the vertebral column
or spinal column each vertebra has two
laminae fused together to form the roof
of the spinal canal
the laminae protect the spinal cord in
the neck and back regions
in the lower back where the spinal cord
ends
the laminae protect the large bundle of
nerve roots
called the cauda equina as well as the
nerve roots exiting the spine
nerve root compression can be caused by
bony spurs from arthritis
a herniated disc compressing the nerve
root
or less commonly a bony tumor of the
vertebra
a laminectomy relieves back and leg pain
caused by this nerve root compression by
removing all
or part of the lamina this immediately
alleviates the pressure on the nerve
root
if a herniated disc is present your
doctor will often perform a discectomy
which directly removes the source of the
compression a laminectomy can be done on
a vertebrae in the lower back
called the lumbar vertebrae or those in
the neck region called cervical
vertebrae
microlaminectomy and microdiscectomy are
procedures performed with the aid of a
microscope
when you arrive at the hospital an
intravenous line will be started
and a catheter may be placed in your
bladder to drain your urine
just before surgery you will be given
either general
or spinal anesthesia spinal anesthesia
is injected into a sac that surrounds
your spinal cord
and numbs the area where the doctor will
be working with spinal anesthesia
you will be awake during the procedure
but you will have no feeling in the
lower half of your body
a laminectomy takes about one to three
hours
you will lie on your stomach or on your
side for the duration of the procedure
your surgeon will begin by making a
small incision
overlying your spine retractors are used
to pull
fat and muscles away from the lamina
using a special bone drill
your surgeon will cut away the lamina in
order to see into the spinal canal
and locate the source of the nerve
compression if a herniated disc
is causing the compression he or she
will perform a discectomy
by removing the protruding part of the
disc to complete the procedure
the deep tissues and incision in your
back will be closed with stitches
after your surgery you will be taken to
the recovery room for monitoring
the nursing staff will regularly check
vital signs and the strength of the leg
on the side of your surgery to be sure
the nerve has not been severely injured
you will be encouraged to get up and
walk as soon as you feel comfortable
if a catheter was inserted before your
surgery it will be removed before you
leave the hospital
if you've had an uncomplicated
discectomy you will likely leave the
hospital the next day
laminectomies performed for other
reasons may require longer hospital
stays